yeah hello welcome to this broadcast
here the first Monday broadcast right
after Christmas I hope you all had a
good Christmas time and yeah feeling a
little bit relaxed them with a couple of
days off from work or whatever you're
doing regularly okay also welcome to all
of you in the twitch chat don't see a
message yet in the twitch chat but I'm
already saw a couple of people online
probably waiting until the video really
comes through
okay I'm going to play um as I usually
do a couple of couple of games going to
kick up with five minutes here playing
mr. Maradona yeah I'm trying to do
something else against them and yeah go
for Queens gambit accepted just try a
different opening I usually play
something else against him the Kings
Indian mostly nîmes oh yeah thanks for
telling me that I'm live
I'm already I suspected that I'm now now
I do it a little bit different they
always make it a little window here on
my desktop that I actually see them sees
the chat I've see the sorry the the
actual broadcast myself so I I see if
I'm live or not something that I should
have done right from the start I guess
okay I just developed my pieces yeah
that looks like a very natural way to
play just get everything out and see
what happens I wonder who maybe I could
have played and I'd be five I'm going to
play a 6 a.m.
now you cannot play for free on the ICC
as I see is a pay only server and I'm
playing the so-called five minute pool
or auto pairing where you get a very
strong opposition Knight to e5 so that's
a little bit awful I cannot take
unfortunately there should be five ge5
well I can again do it maybe come on
let's do it
I'm taking too long him it's not ideal
but okay Luke takes us 95 years to take
with the night but now I have to move my
knight
I was thinking night 2:7 him I'm
attacking a 5 and I have ideas like 95
to d3
yeah hello to all viewers and all the
regulars in the chat we have a couple of
people who are there like every week
hello to go fix mix igniting ideas by
original schweitzer we have a couple of
guys they're everywhere every every time
sorry everywhere people from everywhere
are here every time that is what I tried
to say but not quite managed okay so
what what about this I think I should
try to trade that I just got 95 maybe
hmm but even night he 5 as a move whoo
let's see we'll see if he trades I'm
definitely okay yeah hello also to
Biggus Dickus
he's also robbed every eye
Monday yeah that looks like yes to trade
yeah 95 I'm not quite sure I'm not quite
sure what you're saying as Internet
Chess Club also this is a this is a
twitch account for the internet Chess
Club it's used to stream various content
not just by me but by many many players
so it's a it's a shared account let's
say it's a not my exclusive account
which is the chest explained that I used
for the Christmas streams it's just just
for my just mine let's say and this is
for a different bunch of authors so what
about this now Bishop c4 will take on c5
I think I can do Knight b3 I'm not not
totally into the ascetic about it and
moving the night hmm
I think I will take okay played dad
okay that I didn't expect that that
looks pretty okay for me now
I thought what about this if I go be
five he goes to D - huh
it still looks interesting okay and now
a five was my idea if he has to take I'm
taking with the night and I'm ready for
C 5 C 4 so this looks kind of nice
hello - meat grinder hop gobbling 64
callus 90 yeah nice to see the regulars
there nobody fell into some kind of I
know
induced coma from eating too much over
the Christmas days so what's this C 5 C
4 is an idea just push stuff or just
some C 6 I can go rook b8 actually let's
do that the number is the material
account
like 21 points if you refer like here 21
points yeah I'm I didn't even see that
I'm falling a little bit behind on the
clock yeah I have to be quick now
yeah I'm not 21 years old even though I
look like it so what now I lied to Eve
forum know that blonde is b5 it's not
such a great idea
yeah night night should be three will
take unfortunately okay that's not a big
deal let's do it
I can take him I was thinking this is
good maybe wrong I was thinking this is
good for me
I have rook c8 see force is a key idea
but I couldn't really calculate it
completely this is what I saw
still not totally simple okay let's take
him
oops
didn't see that one and now please night
be eight hoops shoot I didn't see that
one
overlooking stuff him
Nate be ADA have the chicken rookie 5
but I'm not threatening much yeah this
is the problem
he offered me a drawer like I don't need
to accept this this is still something
that you can try to win with rook
against Knight okay okay no I won that
on time
I really don't look against Knight I
mean you can he can play and never got
more time it's just what happens the
porn porn porn porn count is without the
king yeah definitely King would be like
infinite probably so who's that cried
wolf I don't know who that is
let me check Grand Master from Georgia
yeah that that's easy you don't need to
write that in your notes you can spot
that but I don't know the name
okay Steve for hanging here hmm may
might beam let's go back yeah 2500 is
pretty strong Yasmine I agree
we'll see what happens
I'm playing in the center here and see
what he's going to do I mean he's got a
somewhat weakened King position
let's not promote too much I played lots
of bullet yesterday he can take on d4
maybe that's I mean it's not really
correct but interesting okay it didn't
go for that okay so I can check he goes
to age 7 yeah let's go here attack b7
what to do our night on d2 is not that
great maybe I can put it to c5 yeah that
makes lots of sense actually let's see
what are you doing now yeah he's got
some whole stem that he has to worry
about I'm a huge fan of the bishop pair
we're peak rating is to five sixty with
a non non YouTube account and to five
twenty with the just explained account
it's not easy for black here I don't
don't really see what is what is
supposed to do now he has to muddy the
waters but he has some chances maybe
some dynamic chance said I'm not seeing
at the moment not easy though cannot go
deform and b7 is just hanging
I'm also threatening Knight C to d7 CD 7
Bishop d7 25 check King moves and then
take the 7 okay I can do that now here
right ok let's look at it again check
check King age 7 97 yeah I'm not
threatening to take take any of the
rooks though it's kind of funky but I
can go knight c6 of course if we don't
look let the candidate move principle
for one moment let's go there
so what about this 97 and then just
taking it really it's not totally clear
but I can check on d5 as well
hmm 94 is also just very strong actually
let's do that that's a that's a purely
that's a purely positional solution but
not so bad I have a dominating night now
on c6 and he has no play whatsoever at
least I don't see it cannot go g4 and
I'm just having good control with them
and I win an endgame because I seven
faults I think Ian's idea form probably
wasn't the best move
but it's it's pretty good
yeah this is the thing what now
right the 896 is interesting probably
him he's got one check there it's not a
big deal and I think that's right LIGO
was pretty cool actually I always liked
that as a child he's taking a long time
itself it's it sucks this position he
cannot play Queen f6 I just take her
play 96 win ce7 this bishop is a pretty
in pretty bad piece
okay 96 yeah this is funky but I cannot
really believe that works how to do at
night
yeah Knight f8 is a good comic-con let's
let's play let's play technical chess
this is the technical way to do it
how to be precise here f3 or not quite
sure maybe just over to to c6
so what is the easiest way here he will
try to give me that check there it's
actually still kind of annoying Knight
to f3 would be good but I don't quite
see how I get there maybe this one I
cannot go to the 5 that was bad I wanted
to go 95
I was bad bad technical plain no yeah I
was simply bad I was winning one time
but that was terrible it should have
been should have been the clean winner
on the board and not this mess
I couldn't really can really find a win
that that wasn't great
okay let's go no I playing in the
five-minute pool I don't do viewer
challenges here if you want to challenge
one of the GM's on the SSE you have to
shoot form Joe Benjamin for example or
David's murder and they do those Ben
tablet sessions okay let's play yen the
man from the Netherlands and go for the
Trump that's a fun question do you think
you can reach 2600 feet
no definitely not I put it I'd be very
happy to get to 2500 but I'm not very
optimistic I'm not doing much of
studying at the moment concentrating
more on my students um the best German
chess player should be mr. piano right
at the moment we've got the highest
rating but it's always pretty close
Guillaume is also a good player
okay
yeah pretty simple position here
why does white we'll try to play a piece
based attack and yeah this is something
I probably should have paid a little bit
more attention to but I think I'm still
okay
yeah okay it definitely would net points
if you press on every ending even the
very equal ones and so on
it would net points but but yeah I'm I'm
not really much in favor of doing that
why is this such a bad position that
that's that's a good question well I
really must have played some complete
bond sincere that position is really
terrible I didn't even see that I didn't
even see that move Wow
yeah against the Trump you can play a
couple of good things and this is just
one line 94 95
I came he really tries to kill me
probably with successful I'm not sure if
he played the most yeah probably did it
looks pretty terrible yeah nice the
pianos switched federations from Romania
to Germany I think about one one year
ago and but he he's some his I think his
mother always father one of the two is
from Germany so it's kind of a 50/50
so that least there is some kind of
connection not like with the NIDA and
Azerbaijan where there's absolutely no
connection it's a pure money thing with
with him okay so he wants to kill me and
he will kill me probably okay I'm just
taking stuff yeah I just bishop I have a
twins but many things win now you can
play a d4 repertoire with the trauma
sure it's not not a bad opening just
Bishop evade no wins I don't know what
the problem is is he looking for some
kind of beauty prize okay
neither probably also will win a
position is probably so bad that even
that wins even though it wasn't the best
way to do it you can take f6 and play
Queen age 7 that was a bad game I think
I was chatting away there while I build
up a terrible position that was pretty
bad
that was pretty bad I'm not quite sure
what I what I did wrong them I mean this
position should be scanned of okay it's
a bit passive but now 98 is probably
nonsense okay flashlight
FM so I had this Queen's Gambit earlier
no get the London system maybe this is
kind of getting into fashion funny
enough Kramnik usage today to beat to
beat who did he beat should give off
right and we have chronic playing um
playing cars on tomorrow right
yeah I'm shooting for some queenside
play here yeah this is interesting I
think I'm just second here this is an
interesting line normally white players
are usually irritated when that happens
yeah the Trump was an idea of six and
the London versus d5 is a very very
interesting repertoire actually it's a
little effort I mean very interesting
the London can only be that interesting
it's not never going to be a like the
most challenging opening ever but it's
definitely a playable playable option so
if I go here rook a to b4 is that
working
that's right before he might take he
might take but I came bishop takes c4 is
actually good he didn't do that I can't
be happy about that this is good now
yeah I think those two pauses are really
strong what do I think about Isis
replacing 3 plus 1 or 5 plus 5 5 5 0 of
4 3 0 / 3 plus 2 I think it makes I
would personally welcome if they replace
they replace 5 0 with 3 + 2 but this is
mostly because of the commentary I think
the commentary would benefit a great
deal from increment time control we
simply get get more chest more chest
content in so on I would definitely like
that to happen
I go Quincy three to make sure that b2
is happening later the time-saving
opening against you for there are a
couple interesting things that you can
do I think what what I like you
personally and I tend to recommend to
students is the Queens gambit accepted
it's very easy to learn there are only a
couple of lines and I mean you you you
get to that and move to and it's um it's
just two or three lines that you need to
know Queens gambit declined is also
doable but then you have the cattle
learn and all kinds of stuff yeah yeah
is six wins the house okay mister cried
wolf again yeah I read him only on time
in the game earlier after having
outplayed him and then out playing
myself so we get we get a Maroc see
point
you know that's it's just about my
favorite opening yeah I have almost a
100% score with with this in tournament
chess against pretty decent opposition
so let's see what happens him I'm pretty
optimistic
I came nigh to give four
let's see that that looks that looks
funky yeah the BOGO Indian like I
recommend in my book is it just one part
of a big repertoire and you need
something you need the names o as well
so it's not an easy solution on easy to
learn solution so f6
mmm I can also go if I can where 60
we'll take five Bishop h6 okay try to
break through on the light squares the
Ritz eternal book on the Queens gambit
accepted is outdated I think I think I
would shoot for the dash F book they'll
share them cough it sir it's the most
recent one and it's quite okay
I don't think so I think black has
winning ideas with the Queens gambit
accepted especially if you play Bishop
g4 lines against you three even though I
see the point I mean it's not the most
aggressive opening but what exactly is
aggressive wow that's a cool reply but
if I just attack him and don't take the
pawn just route coming over here to h3
isn't that dangerous I get a good
position again against him so f6 pawn
takes okay this is actually strong I'm
ready for Bishop e6 here wow this is a
disaster I asked to take otherwise
Bishop f5 is killing immediately so
let's just hope that I'm winning this
now straight on the board not just some
some stupid time win I can take this
it's not totally clear
hmmm let's just win their porn hmm yeah
but I think this is stronger right I'm
taking this a stronger cannot move the
bishop he cannot move the rook so taking
the pawn
so what about this just back here I
guess
then my rooks are not doing that much if
they would take part in the attack I can
also take before I have rookies 6 ok I'm
just grabbing stuff and he takes rookie
6 so I have to move the Queen I'll move
this yeah I'm moving the Queen is
probably ok somewhere here
probably could have done something
easier but it still doesn't it still
isn't any fun for him
rookie 6 I have Queen age aid maybe
Queenie 626 takes rook T for T for
Bishop III yeah I am that's something
that I should have seen is escaping to
an endgame
it's a very good endgame I have dropped
e7 I had woop d7 damn hmm should have
done that was pretty bad
yeah but can you do have to go with this
hmm I actually should have reconsidered
this if this is really such a great idea
here with a king over to g5
yeah I have to use the green screen
because ICC requested me to do that
if you don't like it right to them I'm
happily discarding it if there's a
majority of people yeah requesting that
I guess is really really making life a
little bit difficult here
oh I'm stupid you can just rake ah
oh my god
I'm playing really like an idiot against
the sky first I'm completely killing him
and then I'm playing like a [ __ ] oh my
god look a fire everything wins
everything wins oh my god
okay so let's see what we can do here at
least we don't have video chats with
opponents I would be pretty distracted
if I have to play the real samurai
yeah that's a material count
I'm not 39 it's not so far away from the
truth but
okay so isn't this with Queen b3 isn't
that tough to defend that Center how is
the defending the center I've had cheek
three b3 I guess he or she if she isn't
know the Danish gambit is not not good
you can decline it you can take it it's
just not a good opening especially the
declines are very a very unattractive
yeah I'm just two points up for
absolutely nothing
yeah I played a couple of attractive
human opponents I really did over the
years I played um I played a mirror
script chenko for example she's not not
bad at all as a player had not not
bad-looking at all but she played a
pretty bad game it was a nice win for me
a couple of years ago yeah yeah I'm too
poor to pawns up and the position but I
completely screwed up screwed up with
the other winning position against that
George and GM are here black just
resigned okay let's go for a new game
yeah there was a pretty straightforward
winner in the London system
my school against female players overall
over 2,200 I have no no idea no idea
it's probably not so bad but cannot
really tell cannot tell it's not not a
bad score most games are probably one
the highest-rated was strip shank oh and
I won against her played a couple of
women between 2300 and 2400 and I think
most of it will be draws or winds for me
I don't recall losses I am of course I
lost against some women but I'm not
quite sure of their rating
yeah this is a pretty pretty lame line
of the of the room is I gave up on the
French defense because not of a
particular line but because I simply
didn't score well simply didn't score
well I don't I don't think a French is a
perfectly fine opening it's just that
you need the right you need to play it
well as with every opening and I simply
had problems with the French on in some
in many positions I just don't
understand the opening well okay well
this is also not very exciting but at
least I have probably have equalized in
this position never ever lost to a kid I
to be honest I don't have I don't have
any any of those losses against little
kids but this is because I don't play I
didn't play a lot lot of tournaments for
a long time and I simply didn't have the
chance to lose games there when I played
a couple of I played a couple of kids
that later become very strong yeah I
played guys like Robert Marcos for
example or Setlock there from from
Serbia and they are now very strong GM's
2600 something and I beat them when they
were kids or Sega Aaron book he also
beat when he was a kid I'm I'm not so
bad against kids it seems I also played
Jordan fan Forrest who's some very
strong and talented - jr. ahead of
totally winning position but screwed up
like two years ago yeah I played Magnus
on the ICC when he was 10 years old and
I thought that this was a prank account
now I have never played any other
brought strategy game in any seriousness
okay it's giving me that rook but I am
more worried about this here play in the
center and crashed through in the middle
yeah beat them rather young that's
pretty true I definitely lost again
against ten-year-old Magnus on the IOC
but those games are lost yeah I try to
recover them but it wasn't possible I
know it there was his account called
Magnus and it said this is Magnus
Carlsen from Norway ten years old and
you simply don't believe that there is a
ten year old playing against you and
he's killing you at least I didn't and
this is why I thought it was a prank
account but it became pretty clear a
couple of years later that it was a
serious account and Magnus Carlsen
actually is a real person the use of of
training books I use a lot actually in
my in my teaching they have very good
examples and good exercises they are
sometimes a little bit on the dry side
if you if you use them on your own but
with the teacher it's a little bit
easier because the other guy I mean Here
I am the teacher I'm selecting the what
are good positions and so on yeah I was
playing cards when he was there ten
years old or 11 years old and at the
time he wasn't famous of course yeah but
when he when he was twelve thirteen he
had those first great tournaments and
why can't see and and everything when he
when he yeah was getting to the close to
the GM title and back then it was clear
it wasn't a prank account and basically
firing moose yeah but I think I think I
have a good very good position
Queen c7 missed maybe but this looks
totally winning if I'm not mistaken the
most aggressive way for black against
Trudeau pass him I don't know actually
there are a couple of lines that look
aggressive like the Schliemann or the
Janna SH gambit but in some cases it's
just an endgame a pawn down so it's not
always so aggressive even if it looks
aggressive on the surface so what this
yeah check and now okay well this wins
the Queen
okay let's win the Queen
yeah it was a pretty pretty straight win
yeah maybe the Schliemann against the
RIP the advantage is that it comes very
early on three and if you play other
lines like a six or something if you go
for a Marshall or so it's it's possible
that they play all kinds of deviations
that are not that are not exciting
anyway yeah it's the Sriman gambit
correct yeah certainly I mean it's
certainly correct on any level below
2800 no problem at all
okay playing Sergey slip up here I
wanted to go for the Queens gambit
accepted try it out but let's play this
then slip back is actually a specialist
of this opening with both colors kind of
interesting to play
I have to go g6 get g7 for one night
yeah raja baath played the Schliemann
also on top level I think it's it's
perfectly okay just it's a bit risky to
play like every game on that level and
he also didn't do it every game but
quite often
yeah I'm just firing moves and hope that
they work sometimes it does if you have
a good flow you can play like this just
move move move and and I okay well okay
but you have to be cautious a rook takes
his six is an idea I would love to play
f6
but g6 is hanging
you know it's a bit uncomfortable
I'm trying 498 here 1986 98 he might
have Queen Texas six as weird as it
looks
and I think tupolev plays many openings
against you for the the only exclusive
night off was a.cian players MVL he
always does that
yeah the perk and modern defense they
tend to go to extremes you have
extremely nice wins or just loose it
happens what are you doing here mr.
sleep hawk he wants to take that home on
c6 I think I'll step away
not sure about this position is I think
I'm kind of okay here
reading f6 now
hmm that should be okay I don't really
see what's going doing much going
anywhere here yeah the Berlin is so
popular on the top level because it
narrows down the let's say the narrows
down the area of explore of exploration
in a way yeah you just have the end game
if you are
okay in the end game you're very likely
okay in the overall opening and the end
game is quite clearly as we see all over
again is quite clearly very solid so
they play it and it's on that level it's
also completely okay to draw with black
so why not they they go for it in the
draw by the way I think that if we if
you look at that Qatar tournament right
that is going on right now that big
event this is an actually very
interesting tournament I think maybe the
the organizers yeah should think about
this kind of event more why not why not
instead of doing a round-robin
Invitational event why not do a big big
Swiss event like that and have the super
top players play there I am and you
don't see so many Berlin and whatever
simply because they have to win with
black yeah and I think it's a very
interesting event with some pretty
pretty cool games at five looks wrong
but I don't see a grain move him
it looks wrong now the Berlin will never
get refuted that's very unlikely it's a
this is openings far too far too healthy
far too solid oh I totally I didn't see
that move at all rook h8 we that's going
to be bad yeah I like the format I mean
and those games like let's say cows and
playing a 2550 Gaia so it's just
interesting yeah it's just interesting
those games and they have to really try
to prove that they're better than than
those guys I mean there are better but
you they really have to have to show I
have to show something for it yeah
that's a bad bad position I certainly
was okay at some point but maybe g5 was
mistimed certainly f5 was wrong
now I can resign but I'm let's try this
Swiss event is boring for the top
players not at all it is exactly the
opposite because they have to win if
they if they don't win they will lose
lots of rating points and this means
they have to fight the Swiss event I
mean I can absolutely assure you that in
this disc event the Qatar tournament
Kramnik carlton giri they play because
they get huge attendance fees they are
not played in form for the for the prize
fund i mean they do but they got they
got huge chunks of money to actually
play and if he would make a swiss event
with really huge prize fund this is
actually what they do with the
millionaire chess yeah doing something
like that huge prize funds and get them
to play swiss events this is interesting
why not everybody can participate in in
theory at least and they really have to
really have to fight yeah it's not not
so easy
so hmm it's this hmm
23 or Quinby 123 Queen before it
actually made that's funny
I can he can for the Queen trade queen
of 825 are stupid I was stupid and that
might win as well
is there some kind of trickery here and
fortunately not unfortunately not King a
seven that's no threat iam now he's got
Quincy five yeah okay always want to try
okay
so let that was a good session after all
I mean this was a bad game at the end
but I think I like the overall play it
was kind of kind of interesting okay I
hope you like the show I'll be back next
year
hmmm yeah next year but also of course
next week next week on Monday I'll put
an announcement video on as usual thanks
for watching I hope you all have a good
start to the new year don't party too
hard have fun but don't kill too many
brain cells bye bye